en República Dominicana avanza la
segunda jornada de la Cumbre
iberoamericana mandatarios de América
Latina España Portugal y andorra
persiguen acuerdos en temas como
sostenibilidad seguridad alimentaria y
transformación digital
decenas de personas esperan definir su
situación migratoria en Canadá tras
cruzar la frontera provenientes de
Estados Unidos esto después de que Joe
biden y Justin crudo firmarán un acuerdo
el viernes para impedir que los
solicitantes de asilo ingresen a Canadá
a través de cruces no oficiales tenemos
análisis
Israel vive hoy por duodécimo sábado
consecutivo una nueva jornada de
protestas masivas por el proyecto de
reforma judicial de Benjamín netania Los
Defensores del plan consideran que
restauraría el equilibrio entre las
ramas del poder pero sus críticos creen
que por el contrario debilitaría a las
altas Cortes
Bienvenidos a una nueva actualización de
noticias en France 24 los acompaña
Daniela Blandón vamos a comenzar en
República Dominicana en donde avanza la
segunda jornada de la vigésimo octava
cumbre iberoamericana en el encuentro de
presidentes jefes de estado y
representantes gubernamentales de
América Latina España Portugal y andorra
los temas clave de la agenda van desde
la seguridad alimentaria hasta la
protección del medio ambiente y la
transición digital más temprano nuestra
enviada especial a Santo Domingo Rosa
Pérez más de unos con todo detalle sobre
la jornada de los últimos discursos que
hemos escuchado ha sido larguísimo
discurso del presidente de Colombia
Gustavo Petro quien además en estos
momentos está dando más declaraciones
todavía a la prensa Y seguramente entre
las preguntas que le van a caer va a ser
la ausencia de referencias al tema de El
Salvador y es que recordemos que en las
últimas semanas ha lanzado muchas
críticas contra el presidente
y contra suoplana de seguridad extrema y
su estado de excepción que dura ya un
año sin embargo
sí que Gustavo Petro ha hecho referencia
a condenado la situación Eso sí en Perú
ha dicho que cómo vamos a celebrar que
Venezuela regrese al sistema
interamericano de derechos humanos y que
al mismo tiempo no condenemos
literalmente que un presidente que
debería estar aquí esté en prisión
preventiva en referencia a Pedro
Castillo otra de las cuestiones que ha
destacado Gustavo Petro ha sido la
necesidad una vez más de cambiar el
paradigma de la guerra contra las drogas
ha señalado que esta guerra no lanzada
por Estados Unidos hace ya 50 años ha
cargado no ha acabado con un millón de
Vidas latinoamericanas y ha propuesto la
capital de Colombia Bogotá como sede
para una reunión latinoamericana para
abordar una cuestión que dice ya no es a
colombiana sino que es americana y
mundial entre otras condenas que hemos
escuchado ha sido la de la presidente
chileno Gabriel boric a lo que ha
llamado La dictadura familiar de Daniel
Ortega en Nicaragua ha dicho que el
mundo que latinoamérica no se puede
quedar callada ante esta situación
recordemos que Daniel Ortega no se
encuentra en la Cumbre sino que está
representado por su canciller ha dicho
también en relación al hecho de que
Nicaragua haya quitado la nacionalidad
unos 300 a ciudadanos que sabe bien
Daniel Ortega que la nacionalidad la
patria se lleva en el alma y no se puede
quitar por decreto entre otras menciones
que han hecho los presidentes
latinoamericanos que han hablado Por el
momento Luis Arce por ejemplo ha hablado
de la necesidad de separar la hoja de
Coca del estigma que acarrea para la
producción de otras sustancias y por
ejemplo Guillermo lasso el presidente de
Ecuador ha sido alguno de los que ha
condenado públicamente la
rusa de Ucrania una cuestión que
recordemos según al borrador al que
hemos tenido acceso no figura en la
declaración de Santo Domingo como tal y
en otras noticias del continente
americano el presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden terminó el viernes en
la noche Su primera visita oficial al
Primer Ministro canadiense Justin trudeo
con un acuerdo destinado a detener el
flujo irregular de migrantes a través de
cruces fronterizos no oficiales decenas
de migrantes a quienes la noticia los
tomó por sorpresa mientras llegaban a
Quebec procedentes de Nueva York esperan
definir su situación migratoria para
hablar de este tema conectamos con
Ricardo almanza Guerrero él es
internacionalista analista y experto en
migración señor almanza le pregunta
primero que todo pues a qué se debe este
récord en solicitudes de asilo Y eso Qué
implicaciones ha tenido para el gobierno
canadiense de justido en los últimos
años
Hola qué tal Muy buenas tardes creo que
estamos ante este fenómeno migratorio
que ha impactado durante ya varios años
en Estados Unidos y que se ve implicado
en los últimos años ya también Canadá
este fue un récord de solicitudes de
asilo de más o menos cuarenta mil
solicitudes en el último año que tuvo
la región de de Quebec específicamente
en la ciudad de Montreal y Bueno ahí se
da uno cuenta de lo que realmente
significa la demanda y del Éxodo masivo
de principalmente migrantes
Centroamericanos que habían llegado a
los Estados Unidos y que se estaba
trasladando a la ciudad del norte de
Nueva York y por lo tanto pues ya se
tenía un problema
gravísimo en el tema de migratorio que
tuvieron que estaban trasladándose ya
estas solicitudes de refugio A Canadá
recordemos que dos de cada tres
solicitudes de Refugio que tuvo Canadá
en los últimos años fueron precisamente
a esta provincia de Quebec y es por ello
que ya la presión política hacia Justin
crudo
muy marcada y requerían ya poner freno A
este paso no oficial que se tenía en una
ciudad muy cercana a Montreal y ya con
este acuerdo migratorio se cierra la
pinza para poder
pues controlar Este paso no oficial
señora almanza y para aterrizar esta
noticia los migrantes Cuáles son esos
cambios concretos que va a haber en ese
acuerdo de Tercer país seguro vigente
entre Estados Unidos y Canadá de ahora
en adelante
Sí este acuerdo es una ampliación del
acuerdo del Tercer país seguro es decir
ahora ya pueden repatriar a los
migrantes que
ingresen de manera ilegal a los países
recordemos que anteriormente se podía
recibir la solicitud de de migrante de
asilo y permanecer en ese país con este
acuerdo prácticamente lo que se está
cerrando es que no se puede no pueden
permanecer en el país de la solicitud de
refugios sino el país de ingreso ya sea
en Estados Unidos o en Canadá y algo muy
puntual Es que este paso es un paso no
oficial es decir ya cierran pinzan este
en este paso no oficial que
específicamente en este paso que hay en
Montreal ya cualquier solicitud va a
poder ser repatriado sin embargo queda
abierto todavía está Laguna jurídica que
en cualquier otra área que no sea
oficial de los puentes fronterizos
puedan puedan este ingresar al país y
solicitar Refugio cuando un migrante
pasa por un puente o de una frontera
oficial puede puede solicitar puede ser
expulsado por el país sin embargo cuando
no pasa por estos pasos oficiales no se
puede repatriar y es ahí donde este
acuerdo toma importancia porque
realmente es aquí en este en este lugar
de de Quebec donde ya van a poderse
repatriados también y este a cambio de
eso bueno está Canadá autoriza la
solicitud de quince mil refugiados
principalmente Centroamericanos que es
lo que dice Centroamericanos
específicamente para que puedan ingresar
a su país sin embargo Bueno este a buena
voluntad de Canadá va a ser insuficiente
ya que pues como lo mencionaba al
principio solamente el año pasado si
tuvieron cuarenta mil cuarenta mil
solicitudes entonces creo que Bueno es
es reflejo del endurecimiento de la
política migratorio migratoria en
Estados Unidos y que ahora se suma
Canadá específicamente en las fronteras
del sur Sí señor Ricardo almanza Muchas
gracias por su tiempo y por sus
explicaciones
al contrario Muchas gracias a ustedes
Bueno continuamos también en el
continente de Estados Unidos al menos 23
personas murieron y decenas resultaron
heridas además cuatro están
desaparecidas a causa de un fuerte
tornado en el estado de mississipí según
autoridades locales y federales El
Tornado que llegó de la mano de fuertes
tormentas eléctricas causó daños a lo
largo de más de 160 kilómetros del sur
de Estados Unidos azotando
principalmente a Silver City y a Rolling
dos pequeñas ciudades al oeste del
Estado las autoridades locales han
enviado apoyo médico y otros recursos de
emergencia
Tratamos de meternos en la parte media
de la casa y lo hicimos entramos allí y
obviamente venía justo detrás de
nosotros Porque Tan pronto como entramos
allí escuchamos un gran estruendo y
luego ya no escuchamos Nada más por un
tiempo y en noticias de América Latina
el presidente de Brasil Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva suspendió indefinidamente
por razones médicas su visita a China
que estaba programada del 27 al 31 de
marzo inicialmente su equipo médico
había dado luz verde para el viaje tras
diagnosticarlo con una neumonía leve sin
embargo la secretaría de prensa de la
presidencia confirmó que se trataba de
una bronconeumonía bacteriana y viral y
que la recomendación es permanecer en el
país en la agenda del encuentro con
sheim Pink estaba previsto renovar Los
lazos con el mercado de exportación más
grande de Brasil así como discutir la
creación de un fondo para la
financiación de la energía verde
y actualizamos noticias sobre Francia
porque la actitud de la policía en la
represión de las manifestaciones de los
últimos días no ha pasado inadvertida
mientras el presidente Emmanuel macron
apoyo a las fuerzas de seguridad el
consejo de Europa aseguró estar alarmado
por lo que llama un uso excesivo de la
fuerza contra los manifestantes que han
salido a las calles en contra de la
aprobación de la Reforma pensional
limpieza en París al día siguiente de
una manifestación masiva contra la
reforma de pensiones los escombros
alrededor de este kiosco destruido son
prueba de la violencia que tuvo lugar
durante la movilización ya se han
llevado a cabo nueve días de
movilizaciones declaradas pero también
hay concentraciones improvisadas y
bandalos mezclados entre los
manifestantes la policía endurece su
respuesta luego de que se conoció que el
Rey Carlos III aplazó su visita a
Francia el presidente de Manuel macron
no ha parado de condenar la violencia en
una democracia no tenemos derecho a la
violencia y Por tanto se exigen nuestras
fuerzas policiales el pleno respecto a
la deontología con la transparencia y el
examen que debe acompañarlo Pero esto no
lo pongo en paralelo con lo que ocurre
en la sociedad No cederemos a la
violencia y la condeno con la mayor
firmeza
el diario lemont reveló una secuencia de
más de 20 minutos grabada por un grupo
de personas detenidas en la que se
escuchan bofetadas y amenazas de los
agentes de policía en un comunicado
citando a su presidenta el consejo de
Europa el principal organismo de defensa
de Derechos Humanos en el Continente
manifestó su preocupación por el uso
excesivo de la fuerza contra los
manifestantes
se han producido incidentes violentos
algunos de ellos dirigidos contra
agentes del orden pero los actos
esporádicos de violencia por parte de
algunos manifestantes u otros actos
reprobables cometidos por otras personas
durante una manifestación no pueden
justificar el uso excesivo de la fuerza
por parte de los agentes del estado
estos actos tampoco bastan para privar a
los manifestantes pacíficos del Disfrute
del derecho a la libertad de reunión
según el Ministerio del interior 441
agentes del orden resultaron heridos
durante las manifestaciones del jueves
en una jornada que dejó al menos 457
personas arrestadas
y una nueva jornada de multitudinarias
protestas tiene lugar en Israel por el
proyecto de reforma judicial por
duodécimo sábado consecutivo miles de
manifestantes salieron a las calles de
tel aviv para oponerse a los planes del
gobierno de Benjamín netaniahu de
reformar el sistema de justicia y
limitar el poder de la Corte Suprema
grupos civiles han convocado a partir de
este domingo una semana de parálisis
cuando se espera que el parlamento
apruebe definitivamente el proyecto que
busca aumentar el control del ejecutivo
sobre el sistema judicial entre más
relacionados por ejemplo con la elección
de jueces
y Polo César ballena quien inspiró la
película hotel Ruanda y acérrimo crítico
del presidente pulgadame quedó en
libertad después de que el gobierno
comunicara que había conmutado su pena
por terrorismo pero este opositor que
ayudó a salvar a más de mil personas
durante el genocidio holandés en 1994 no
ha visto todavía anulada su condena
la pena de 25 años de prisión impuesta
al opositor ruandés sabajina ha sido
conmutada por decreto presidencial el
gobierno sostiene que a ojos de la ley
sigue siendo culpable de terrorismo
[Música]
no hay duda de que se cometieron delitos
no hay duda de que se respetó el
procedimiento adecuado y no hay duda de
que el señor rusa ballena fue condenado
porque se lo merecía
sobre este punto no hay duda
inspiró la película nominada al Oscar
hotel Ruanda basada en el rescate de más
de 1000 personas durante el genocidio de
los tutsis del país en 1994 su
Liberación se produce tras meses de
negociaciones entre Estados Unidos donde
él residía y Ruanda la detención de
Rusia ballena en 2020 fue criticada por
Estados Unidos y también por Bélgica
país que él es ciudadano así como por
varias ong
la decisión de secuestrarlo de meterlo
en un jet privado para llevarlo por la
fuerza de vuelta a Ruanda demuestra que
ni siquiera ellos creen en la
legitimidad de las pruebas en su contra
en 2021
crítico del presidente ruandés Paul
kagame fue condenado por mantener
vínculos con el frente de liberación
nacional que kigali considera grupo
terrorista Bruce sabalina que vivía en
el exilio desde 1996 ha admitido su
pertenencia a un partido político pero
niega cualquier vinculación con
atentados terroristas del fnn
y así despedimos este resumen
informativo quédense con nosotros
[Música]